javier asensio y el cost están ustedes
dos a punto de estrenar una miniserie de
la cual son autores el título de esta
miniserie es the reminder de qué se
trata quién de los dos puede comenzar a
explicarnos cuál es la idea de esta
propuesta
bueno donde ver minder es como bien
dijiste una serie miniserie web de
cuatro episodios en quebec
se trata de guy o en francés
qué es un joven de mi edad
es bueno actúa así que que se dirige
hacia el aniversario de unos amigos en
auto cuando tiene un accidente y el auto
deja de funcionar entonces se vuelve
envuelto en
nada que estar solo en la ruta
en el bosque de quebec sin señal sin
ayuda iba a encontrar un lugar que lo va
a esperar con una serie de eventos
desafortunados se suele decir cuando se
trata de realizadores que no son
originarios de que ve en particular o de
canadá en general que producir
audiovisual producir películas producir
cortos producir cine en general series
para televisión es una tarea complicada
en este caso imagino yo que será
cuádruplemente complicada ya que se
trata de una miniserie de cuatro
capítulos es así o fue mucho menos
complicado de lo que uno supone
bueno evolucionó originalmente esto era
un cortometraje
y nos dimos cuenta que el formato
iba a ser más efectivo siendo una serie
de cuatro episodios cortos que la gente
pudiera hacer lo que llaman click bites
watching es decir mirar uno luego del
otro a continuación del otro y en fin
sin sentir que recibir un vídeo de 20
minutos y decir bueno lo miro más tarde
esa fue una una razón principal para
cambiar el formato y respecto a la
dificultad
no sé si y especialmente cuatro veces
más dificultoso es dificultoso para
nosotros como inmigrantes
a realizar con los fondos que deberíamos
y demás y más estando ambos con nuestras
ocupaciones o sea trabajamos de otras
cosas y demás sí
y bueno todo lo que todo lo que incluso
rodar de base es es una industria que
requiere mucha gente de equipos grandes
de gente a veces puede ser una docena de
personas o a veces centenares en nuestro
caso como es algo independiente no no
éramos más que una docena entre sonido
arte realización luces catering etcétera
y si sólo coordina de eso es puede ser
muy difícil así que
el resto de javier puede hablar de un
poco lo que es y una vez que es rodaste
como puede dificultarse y en ese caso
entonces le tratamos la pregunta javier
como se dificultó una vez que está todo
el material rodado que es lo que sigue
que han hecho a ustedes en todo caso
es difícil la palabra la palabra
dificultad para mí
aún las dificultades son una fiesta con
nada en el sentido que a ti te hago una
aclaración porque recibimos presentaste
quizás el inconsciente que te informo de
eso pero ese escrita y dirigida por adam
y yo escribía el film
este hicimos una colaboración anterior
donde donde lo trabajamos juntos después
quizá más adelante vuelvo a eso por eso
te decía quizás como mis ganas de
realizar a través de la música por eso
adoro la música de film y con respecto
bueno volviendo al tema de la dificultad
del filme en realidad es
es tan tan espontáneo como como surgen
los elementos desencadenantes de
inspiración y con adame siempre como una
especie de juego puede ser hasta irónico
puede ser
en este caso precisamente la anécdota
fue adam que me llama desde desde su
trabajo de su compañía estaba en el
ascensor creo y me dice escuchen y me
graba un sonido con su celular y me dice
escucha esto que es esto que suena como
un un abejorro un sonido
paralelamente yo estaba con un 2 y
abierto trabajando en una composición
mía para el cual había recibir una beca
donde me permitía explorar muchísimos
técnicas tímbricas de la utilización de
cuerdas como técnicas de arco como
generar sonidos y texturas un poquito
más extrañas y me tomo un par de horas
hacer un esbozo un borrador y dije bueno
porque ese sonido que adame había
enviado
sonaba en mi cabeza realmente como como
una cuerda frotada de algo que yo estaba
haciendo en este momento
grabé algo rápidamente un par de cosas
bastantes desagradables
el francés no estoy bien
molestas me acuerdo a una latitud en
peor que el dentista
y se lo dan y la respuesta de adán fue
completamente inesperado porque como nos
sucede a veces a los compositores
trabajamos muchísimo largo le ponemos
mucho empeño y después alguien la
respuesta esa es muy bonito idea veces
haces algo súper responder o muy rápido
que no le das mucho valor y del otro
lado sucede como lo que sucedió adam que
le encantó y me dijo si desapareces ya
tengo la música para el filme así que
ese fue el punto de partida para este
para para la música y una vez que que
bueno que la vía ya estaba trazada con
respecto a esta textura sonora lo que
siguió fue ir desarrollando continuar la
exploración con bueno lo hice con una
violinista excepcional que se llama
andrea and gamble
y empezamos a grabar capas de cuerdas
cómo trabajar todavía la textura y
paralelamente un poco en cuál es el tema
que iba a aparecer en la el tema la
armonía de la serie
adam y al igual que ha ocurrido con
muchos realizadores este ha sido un año
bueno no solamente para los realizadores
para todo el mundo pero específicamente
para los realizadores ha sido un año de
desafío es un año muy particular un año
de pandemia qué
puesto en
veremos en suspenso muchísimas
producciones audiovisuales cómo te las
arreglas te para decidirte a encarar y
encarar definitivamente este proyecto
precisamente en un año tan particular
bueno por suerte el proyecto estaba
rodado antes de que empezara la pandemia
durante la pandemia hicimos mucho de lo
que es el montaje la post-producción el
police en cómo se llaman
perdón no me recuerdo las palabras pulir
el pulido
de esa post-producción pero bueno
también requiere desafíos porque uno no
se puede juntar con la gente y hablar en
persona desarrollada de códigos y demás
pero creo que no es bueno saberlo lo
conozco de antes entonces era era más
fácil y se dio como el bien mencionó que
el encontró el sonido que necesitaba en
la serie y pues yo les había dicho
quiero que sufran en el buen sentido
porque es un thriller tiene que estar
tenso y dije que tienen que sufrir y ese
test es como que ahí empezó a hablar más
el corto yo lo había predicado pero como
siempre nos ocurre a los realizadores
al principio de si su puesto no va para
ningún lado no nos funciona y luego
bueno hay algo que puede hablar y
después si esto está bastante bien y
está contento o satisfecho pero es como
una una curva y en él en cuanto a la
pandemia en ese sentido tuvimos bastante
afortunados porque ya habíamos rodado
el rodaje no fue fácil necesariamente
decidí actuar
tengo un background
en actuación más que nada en teatro pero
sabía que iba a ser difícil de coordinar
pandemia o sin pandemia
respecto de las disponibilidades los
lugares donde podíamos rodar y demás
entonces le dije bueno si actúo no
necesitamos ir a buscar o depender de un
actor de montreal que venga y esté
disponible y justo en ese momento que se
desbloqueó tal lugar entonces lo
resolvimos un poco de esa manera y tenía
ganas de ver qué es lo que lo que podía
suceder de dirigir y actuar al mismo
tiempo
que definitivamente no sé si repetiría
porque esto es un poco
como dicen a cada lado de gillette
a ciegas no ves no ves los encuadres
cómo están quedando y demás tienes que
ir y ver y perder tiempo entonces es
distinto que estar detrás de cámara pero
bueno no sé si me extendía un poco en la
respuesta nuestro perfecto y javier en
una entrevista anterior con nuestro
colega pablo gómez barrios tuvo habías
dicho que en ese momento no recuerdo
exactamente cuándo fue hecha esa nota
había llegado el momento de dedicarte a
una obra musical pura decir no de
ponerle música a un trabajo audiovisual
sino de encarar tu realización musical
personal que te llevó a volver entonces
a la musicalización de en este caso una
miniserie a ver exactamente es excelente
es tu pregunta en realidad es que
nunca volvemos siempre estamos en
paralelo y era exactamente eso que le
había mencionado a pablo en esa época
era esta obra en la cual yo ya había
comenzado la exploración en el momento
en que adam me envía ese mensaje yo
estaba trabajando justamente en eso y
paralelamente seguía seguir trabajando
bien por supuesto que cuando entró la
serie fue como un buen un buen trabajo
intensivo que me dediqué a la música de
la serie sin dejar de avanzar de a poco
y al mismo tiempo inspirarme de las
nuevas cosas que aparecían para esta
obra
esta obra personal que que pienso
terminar alrededor de junio
de este año
no estás trabajando no está todavía
exactamente es una hora para una
orquesta de cuerdas y piano y es la
primera vez en buenos nueve años que no
sé si sería apropiado decir invertir el
proceso o que me parece que es una
extensión del mismo proceso de la
escritura de música la imagen
simplemente que esta vez
la inspiración es una historia que yo
quiero contar a través de la música es
como si estuviera escribiendo la música
para el film que siempre me hubiese
gustado que exista y quizás puede venir
y quizás no es un film quizás es una
instalación multimedia quizás es otro
toma toma otra forma pero lo que sí me
doy cuenta y que por eso nos entendemos
también con adam es también me gusta
contar muchas historias con la música
los dos son inmigrantes los dos son de
origen argentino si no me equivoco los
dos llegaron aquí seguramente con muchos
sueños y con la idea de poder dedicarse
cada uno a lo suyo que más hace única a
esta miniserie que
justifique que la gente se conecte para
verla cuál sería la otra característica
que ustedes dirían que la diferencia del
resto de las propuestas que justo este
año de pandemia que están tan volcadas
al mundo digital
de qué me salgo de la vaina por
responder como decir gente en argentina
porque es el río porque yo insisto mucho
con el significado de las cosas que a
nada más
aunque el a veces no habla mucho pero
para mí siempre hay muchísimo contenido
en lo que en lo que hace y pienso que en
este caso la serie representa yo no
puedo evitar de hacer el paralelo con lo
que está sucediendo en él en este
momento como a nivel planetario como
humanidad en el sentido en que el
personaje de esta ser y no quiero
adelantar mucho
se ve confrontado
a mirar cosas que no quería ver qué
cosas que no sabía quizás que existían y
que podían ver
las típicas cosas que enterramos digamos
que podemos llamarlo el invisible que
podemos llamar heridas sufrimientos lo
que no queremos ver y es lo que es un
poco lo que está sucediendo desde hace
ya vaya va a ser un año es como que este
confinamiento nos obliga a estar dentro
de cuatro paredes y enfrentarnos con
cosas que no queríamos ver antes porque
teníamos la posibilidad de ir al bar de
juntarnos con amigos etcétera así que
para mí eso es un poco el sentido de
estas series
más miras al costado peor las cosas se
manifiestan en el exterior y eso es un
poco lo que yo traté de hacer también
con mi música qué es lo que me vuelve
loco de ideas de componer la música no
que mi pasión es es tratar de mostrar el
invisible de revelar lo que no se ve
y adam desde el punto de vista visual
cuál diría que es la característica
esencial de esta miniserie
y para completar un poquito sobre lo que
habló javier de hecho justamente creo
que hace dos o tres días le escribí a
javier sobre una entrevista que había
realizado para un festival de otro
proyecto que hemos realizado
anteriormente que se llama el tiempo del
agua y mirando la entrevista en un
momento digo si esto esto habla también
de es una protagonista femenina es otro
tipo de historia otro tipo de género
pero en el otro caso también decía habló
un poco sobre enfrentar las pérdidas y
si de repente le dijo a javi como se
mira que tanto siempre estoy hablando de
lo mismo
y en ese sentido yo creo que las
historias están todas contadas ahora
siempre hay una nueva mirada una nueva
forma también de expresarla en este en
este proyecto tenía ganas de ir algo que
fuera un thriller algo más
no sé si un poco suena un poco espeso
nativo pero más más de entretenimiento
genuinamente o sea que la gente se queda
enganchada y tratando de seguir el hilo
lo máximo posible y
sin largar hasta el final que en otros
proyectos que hicimos tal vez es un
público un poco más más
restrictivo o más culturalmente
específico que en éste
yo creo que distintas personas de
distintos rubros se pueden identificar
con el solo hecho desde una persona en
aprietos tratando de de salir adelante
y después respecto a lo más distintivo
eso creo que es la música es una bomba
la banda sonora es de otra de otra
calidad de lo que uno puede consumir en
un proyecto de esta envergadura
que no es no es una película de desdén y
no hay otros recursos y otras cosas sin
embargo no se quedaría chica la la banda
sonora en ese sentido
y creo que una de las razones por la
cual trabajamos entonces por qué porque
todavía de nivel no gran sabe quién es
javier pero pero cuando se avanza
y como creadores como ver el futuro de
ustedes en particular pero del mundo
artístico en general se volverá a lo que
antes se llamaba normalidad se seguirá
con esta línea de trabajo en el cual el
principal canal de difusión sigue siendo
o es por el momento al menos el mundo
digital como como vende se va a
desenvolver esto a futuro cuáles son sus
expectativas
y para comenzar no no creo que se pueda
volver a lo que llamamos normalidad
no creo que se deba volver tampoco por
varias razones
si hablamos si hablamos solamente del
contexto artístico de nuestro medio
concretamente había una cierta ahí hay o
había una cierta precariedad que que ya
estábamos digamos artísticamente en el
respirar con el respirador artificial
creo que lo que vino a ser la pandemia
es mostrar que todo se derrumba porque
las cosas necesitan que sean construidas
hechas de otra manera
eso con respecto a volver a la
normalidad yo pienso que deberíamos que
debemos o el proceso natural va a ser
una transformación que es no lo sé no lo
sé
en el arte de la música del arte visual
la escritura yo creo yo creo que
acompañado al ser humano desde los
tiempos más remotos no pienso que es
algo que va a desaparecer no me preocupa
eso tampoco yo pienso que es buscar
buscar la manera en la cual vamos a
poder compartir crear y continuar a
continuar nutriéndonos para hacer
cambiar y evolucionar este sistema
adam desde el punto de vista de la
creación d
películas series de la creación visual
como ves tu futuro en particionar y la
creación en general
son en mi cotidiano el trabajo para una
compañía de videojuegos soy director de
la cinematografía
y en ese sentido lo veo lo vean presente
o sea
las producciones e incluso en film y
televisión están se están transformando
están adaptándose a distintas
circunstancias ya lo estaban haciendo
antes de la pandemia con todo lo que sé
en realización digital
o sea y trabajado en filmes de otros
realizadores un poco más conocidos
donde todos los planos
que hacíamos una gran cantidad de los
planos que hicimos fueron fueron hechos
en la computadora o sea
sin la presencia del protagonista
incluso a veces los reproducimos a nivel
digital con modelos y demás y se está se
está haciendo cada vez más accesible del
mismo modo que hoy nosotros para una una
serie independiente podemos tener acceso
a una cámara que pueda hacer 4k etcétera
que hace
y diez años y usher impensables rodará
un tipo de resolución
de manera independiente y con un
resultado visual tan nada tan de buena
calidad yo creo que la parte de
realización de 3d también se ha
digitalizado hay cada vez más estudios
que están
utilizando motores de juegos como a
nuria y están reemplazando desde
como se diría environments desde los
lares los entornos gracias hasta a veces
se están y tengo guiones que los hago
leer por una computadora o sea escucho
las diferentes voces entonces puedo
tener una sensación del ritmo de los
personajes de
de cómo entregan ese texto si bien es un
robot es bastante bastante sorprendente
pues puedes tener una idea de una obra
de modo que no planificamos antes yo
creo que en ese sentido técnico técnico
artístico se está evolucionando y va a
seguir evolucionando
incluso más con la pandemia el acceso
también a la informática del hardware es
cada vez más impresionante de hecho para
hablar de cosas de algunas limitaciones
técnicas que tuvimos con el core todo lo
que estaba rodado en 4k y demás a veces
tenemos tonos con el proceso de
rendering y justo una de las personas
que hacían los títulos sólo los títulos
renderizar los títulos para la serie de
más demorada como 12 horas y ahora que
estuvimos cambiando máquinas
hacer la persona privada que quien se
ocupó de diseñar los títulos me dice
bueno con la nueva máquina lo saben 40
minutos es una locura
el nivel de proceso de la imagen y ley
que al fin y al cabo es información
después con ser voces pueden ser modelos
pueden ser texturas
el mundo se está transformando en una
manera digital que es
esa pausa donde yo creo que eso
acompañar y va a seguir cada vez más
el tiempo vélez jesús nos está apurando
entonces para hacerlo corto para ir
cerrando mejor dicho
para ver esta miniserie que ustedes van
a estrenar este jueves qué es lo que
tiene que hacer el público que esté
interesado donde puede verlo hacia dónde
debe recurrir cómo accede a ella
crece el caviar
es que en realidad te encargas voz sí
bueno compartir el link pero va a ser
sobre vídeo si no me equivoco si es
sobre vídeo en los cuatro episodios van
a estar disponibles o sea ya lo están
pero están bajo password vamos a liberar
el password el jueves a las 20 horas de
quebec
y nada el link va a estar disponible en
la en la página de la entrevista la
lengua de las series está hablada en
inglés mayormente y están todos todos
los subtítulos disponibles en español en
francés de quebec francés internacional
japonés en que más alemán de pronto y me
olvido alguno
no estoy tramitando el hebreo con
alguien en israel pero vamos a bueno y
hay un tiempo límite de acceso o la
gente podrá acceder a la miniserie
cuando quiera
por lo pronto va a ser va a estar
abierto pero tenemos que dar porque ya
fue enviado alguna serie de festivales y
puede ser que nos pidan de retirarlo
eventualmente así que aprovechen
mientras está disponible
y si no después serán los lugares de
festivales
donde sea entonces a partir de este
jueves a las 20 horas the reminder de
javier asensio que nada por todo
básicamente o principalmente la música
pero no excluyente mente es un creador
multifacético y dirigirá esta miniserie
por adam el coche con ambos hemos tenido
el placer de hablar en esta ocasión y
espero poder tener una a futuro también
muchísimas gracias por esta entrevista a
los dos con radio canadá internacional
muchas gracias a ustedes gracias muchas
gracias por tu tiempo